A dress causes controversy!
Kanye West said WHAT?!
And my man, LP stops vlogging.
I'm Gloriyah Burger and this is PEW NEWS!
poopooopoopoo
poopoopoopoopoopoopoopoopoopoopoopoopoo
StOp!!
Brad or Brad 2, what the heck are you doing?? You're supposed to edit the lasers so they come from my fingers.
Instead you just blast them like all across the screen! What am I even paying you for?
(pause)
B2: Hello!
B1: Brad 2, it's Brad 1.
This boy thinks we've got time to actually
track the lasers coming out of each of his individual fingers (laughing)
(Laugh continues)
Like we ain't-
B2: He's mental!
B1: Like we ain't got better sh*t to do with our day!
(more laughing)
B2: I know, right? Like he's not paying us enough, man. What the hell?
B1: He don't pay us ANYTHING! On top of that,
we've got an hour to edit each of these every day.
B2: But he's literally making us into slaves like this- this is ridiculous. Man this is ridiculous.
*cue dope intro music*
Good evening, I'm Gloriyah Burger
Your favorite new-
The most reputable news source in this entire world. Our first story comes from Twitter-
and my god is everyone tweeting this at me.
So apparently some guy got really mad and upset that some girl who is not Chinese
wore a Chinese dress to prom and she's not allowed to do that because that's cultural appropriation
and a ChInGa ChInGa ChInG cHoN- I'm not gonna do a racist Chinese accent for this.
That would just be horrible and racist
I'm not like Jeremy just dropping "n" bombs and other racist-
derogatory terms left and right while calling other people out.
Wait a minute
disgusting
hurtful language.
getting in-culturally appropriated right now.
someone is wearing something that they are not allowed to wear.
And that's just- that's just mean and hurtful.
I'm glad we have people like Jeremy Lam-
Literal Saints (100%)
calling these people out.
after being called out for
(laughs) for all this.
Yes, I used to be more ignorant than I am now
My youth was not perfect. It was problematic
What?
Can we all just have a round of applause for Jeremy? I think he's got enough of it.
He had a
non-perfect youth everybody.
All right so to summarize, in case I didn't explain it well enough-
this guy just found this girl on Twitter, and she was wearing a Chinese dress and he
made this tweet and it got a lot of retweets.
to take it upon himself to speak for all Chinese people, or all Chinese women for that matter-
It's not like he's worn the dress
Just be honest and say what it is, you wanted retweets online.
You wanted attention and you knew exactly how to get it.
I'm sick of it. I don't even want to waste any more time on it. Let's move on!
poPOpopoPOPoPpoPo
(pause)
(Pewds continues) Sorry. I forgot to tell you, if you guys want to stop cultural appropriation-
Just buy the hat. This Cyka hat merch
it's got five days left on it before- before we never sell it again and
we don't ship to Russia (rip slavs) so that means anyone, but Russians can wear it.
And today in awesome news guys
Orange shirt kid finally was made into a dancing Fortnite. Remember orange shirt kid?
*beautiful music thanku brads*
He didn't win the Fortnite boogie-down challenge, so he would be made into a dancing Fortnite, and everyone got really mad.
*beautiful music again*
And he should've- CLEARLY should've won! This is the best dance I have ever seen in my life.
Well
I got good news for you
It's made into a dance. How great! I'm sure he's going to get part of the revenue of course. Now this is all thanks to-
fabricated social media outrage.
(swede laughs)
That's started by Dolan Dark
Starting the hashtag #JusticeforOrangeShirtKid campaign. For real I think it's cool that Epic Games finally listened.
uhuuhuuhuh
He deserved to win. It's sort of not funny anymore. I feel like now, it's
the meme is dead, and I truly understand how people feel when I review a meme.
I mean when PewDiePie reviews a meme on meme review. I get it now!
Next News!
PEw PewPew
Today in awesome news A.S.S. is coming out of every single console ever, in May!!
pOoo POoo poo POo pOo p00 pew
And today an awesome news, Logan Paul stopped daily vlogging (finally!)
Wait a minute
Are you telling me someone that is making less ad revenue than ever and probably selling less merch than ever
decided to go on another path of earning revenue. I don't understand this
I don't understand it at all.
(Help the broke child)
Please buy a hat in case you haven't already.
Honestly legit- I I am making more on selling these hats this month than I'm making on ad revenue despite uploading daily content.
Do you understand how bad ad revenue is? I might as well not even call myself a youtuber. I'm a hat merch-
I'm a hat salesman at this point. That is my profession.
And really just- I want to thank YouTube for having such great way of monetizing on their platform.
It's it's wonderful. I'm so thankful.
(Flawless work YT)
*more pews*
You probably notice Kanye West has been tweeting a looot.
Lately among things, what he tweeted was "I love the way Candace Owens thinks".
This got a lot of news coverage and it became sort of a controversial statement, let's see why-
why that is. "Victim mentality is not cool. I don't know why people like being oppressed its the weirdest thing I've ever heard
'I love oppression! We're oppressed! 400 years of slavery! Jim Crow!'
Which by the way none of you guys lived through. Your grandparents didn't.
It's embarrassing that you utilize- you utilize their history. You're not living through anything right now.
You're overly privileged Americans!" then following up with "self victimization is a disease"
"We have freedom of speech, but not freedom of thought" now
I talked about ego a few videos back, and I realize now
I I was wrong. Kanye has such a massive ego
And he was so aware of it that he doesn't back down of what other people are criticizing him for which is so
rare these days, the fact that everyone just backs down is what has created this polarizing
Climate of ideas where we all know in a public setting. What ideas are
Allowed to be said and what ideas are just plainly not and a lot of times common
Sense is forbidden because it doesn't fall in the pool of thoughts that
We're allowed to say or allowed to think because they're somewhat controversial and they they get attached to all these
Extremist groups when really a lot of times
We're just talking common sense obviously
Kanye thinks like this because he's a very
successful guy
If anything it's nice to see people staying true to their ideas because for too long everyone is bought into the same sort of mentality
I've done that mistake myself for example here with the case of the dress
I'm glad that keziah decided not to delete the the tweet and be proud of her dress just because this sparked public outrage
Doesn't mean that she thought she was wrong and she- in my opinion, she wasn't next POOOOO
what the fu-
"Nice to see you Danny
I'm going to take a nap" let's talk about Avicii
you guys probably heard of was it a few weeks ago Avicii he died and
It sort of came as a surprise if you've seen photos of him near the the death
You could tell something was wrong Avicii died of apparent suicide
He really struggled with thoughts about meaning life happiness, and he could not go on any longer
He wanted to find peace this whole story sort of
Hit a bit too close home for me with
Young Swedish guy. I think he was he was my age even
From Sweden he described himself as an introvert. He just had a passion and it became successful obviously
I'm nowhere near successful as Avicii, but it's
I
It's it's too similar to me. I feel like you know in another universe this could have been me
I obviously don't know Tim. I never met him
it's not really fair on me to project a bunch of ideas around it in 2016 Tim Bergling had stopped touring because
He had some health issues, but he also said "to me, It was something
I had to do for my health the scene was not for me
It was not the shows and not the music it was always the other
Stuff surrounding it that never came natural to me all the other parts of being an artist
I'm more of an introverted person in general. It was always very hard for me
I took on board too much negative energy. I think" I can imagine Tim. Just wanting to create music. He's a passionate guy that
Became successful everything that came with it was just too much. I don't know
I'm just speculating I know it's not really fair of me to do
But I want to be able to discuss this at least or what I think about it because a lot of people look at people
That are successful, and they just think how could they commit suicide
They have everything and I'm not saying that so that I would get some sort of pity or like oh, it's so hard
It's really that's not it at all. I'm just saying it for you guys, so you understand that this whole idea of
fetishizing
Success in a way that it's the ultimate goal
that if you get popular then you've acquired everything and if you've acquired money
then that's all that matters because it really isn't and
We really need to stop thinking that way. I've talked about happiness a lot on this channel. It's a topic
I discussed a lot because I've seen so many people struggle with it you youtubers
I mean because I think constantly being evaluated by numbers as soon as you make one mistake it will seem like the whole
Your whole fan base and everyone has just turned against you. With a tragedy like this
I feel like I want to do something about it. I feel like I can do something, but I don't know what
When I filmed scare PewDiePie I think that was the worst time for me when I did YouTube because I felt so trapped
Doing something that I didn't really want to do I was taken away from what I really wanted to do was  to make videos
but
My network at the time had just put up so many projects and so many things on me
I was stuck doing things that I didn't want to do even though
I had the dream laid out for me and as an introvert a lot of times things that seem, seem attractive and
Amazing things is just a chore and and a pain and it's not for everyone. I realize in a way now
I'm talking about Tim's suicide in a way that for me to talk about my own problems
But I do think they correlate in a sense. I did like I said, I don't know Tim
I don't know what he went through, but what from what I can gather at least
I feel like I can at least understand it to some degree we're so stuck on this idea that successful people have everything
It makes it even harder to open up about these issues
I'm just really really sorry and my thoughts go out to Tim's family and
His friends and his fans that was it for pew news everybody way to end it on a high note
Thank you for leaving like thumbs this video check out the merch and all that stuff. I'm Gloriyah Burger, and this is Pew News!
See you see you next
You don't get an outro you don't deserve one
thats it go away